we're tapping into this Supply zone
right here it's going to respect the
supply Zone it's going to return back
into our liquidity Zone because what you
can see here last night in New York Red
news for USD really bullish last night
Asia we just had some dead consolidation
it's price is respecting the supply Zone
and it's going to retrace off that what
we're going to see is a selloff see a
change of character at some point so we
do see price come back into our buy side
liquidity then we can start looking for
some sales and I'm thinking this is
going to be a really nice trade that
change of character we were talking
[Music]
about I took 50% partials trade like
this would literally pass my F Well
phase one we're here with Ain s on so
a you didn't answer my question from
last
time would you rather get bummed by your
grandad
your
grandma that's four open up
doors yeah I count too hot without
spinning too much yeah I get that girl
when I get that of course oh my money on
C be s in the yard money on weight
PA yeah yeah yeah
yeah let me go let me go let me go
yeah hey
yeah I can be de
[Music]
little so it's the end of that video
boys start trying to customize my live
stream hopefully tomorrow morning you
guys should see uh a few little
additions to try and Spruce things up a
little bit hope you guys have enjoyed
this video and we go again tomorrow it's
the last [__] day come on come on